[Music]
k is in raleigh north carolina hi kay
welcome to the ramsey show
hi thanks dave
um going along with the theme here today
i think of car
questions
we have gotten ourselves into quite a
bit of credit card debt over the past
year
and
i'm wondering
we are
doing the plan right now and we're very
gazelle intense and we have a lot of
stuff that we're selling
my husband's income is getting ready to
go up
in december and he's also getting ready
to get quite a few bonuses
um in the next couple of months
and i'm wondering if we
could wait for some of that stuff to
happen and continue to be
gazelle intense
before we think about
selling one of our cars
or if we should just do it now and
then you know whenever that extra money
comes in i guess it's just extra money
okay why are you selling the car
to pay off the credit card debt oh
i see
okay
so what what is the car the cars worth
what are they worth
we have a um like a classic sports car
that's paid off that probably right now
is worth
about thirty thousand dollars
um my car and then he drops that off
um
he actually yes quite a bit i mean he
doesn't it's not a daily driver oh so
it's a third car it's a third car it's a
third car okay so you have a thirty
thousand dollar third car and the second
car is what
what are your [ __ ] car what was it
worth it
it's worth probably right now about 35
to 40 and it's paid off okay and what's
the next one
the next car
is
we do have a loan on that for 30 000 and
it's probably worse right now about 40.
okay and so
it sounds like you have a hundred and
ten thousand dollars worth of vehicles
yes and what is your household income
it's about
160
and by the end of the year it should be
about 200.
okay
um well i mean the rule of thumb that we
use is to not have too much tied up in
things that are going down in value and
our definition of that is when you have
more than 50 percent of your household
income tied up in things with wheels and
motors
then you've got too much tied up and
things are going down in values makes it
mathematically hard to get ahead
you are you guys are car poor
for sure
now if you got ten thousand dollars
worth of cars or a hundred thousand
dollars worth of cars and you make 200
you're right on the bubble on that okay
so no i would not sell those cars based
on that formula
uh the other formula we look at is can
you be debt free except the house if you
keep all of these things in 24 months
so you have 50 000 in credit card debt
and you have
uh 40 or 30 000 in car debt that's 80
what other debt do you have not counting
your house
nothing
okay so can you pay off 80 in 24 months
yeah you probably can
so if you love if you love these cars i
would keep them but and but i also want
you guys to look at each other and go we
were right on the bubble on stupid
and we don't need to get up on this
bubble again
okay because you don't get rich buying
cars
no
and you guys have invested a large chunk
of your lives
in cars
and so they're right on the bubble and
if you love all three of the cars and
you want to hold them
you're going to be in a position shortly
to have kept them and that makes sense
mathematically but you really have to
address
um
your addiction to automobiles
because you're gonna struggle if you
don't that that's the whole process
so
um hey but you're right there i i'm with
you i would probably keep them and i'd
probably pay them all off but
the only caveat is just go you know if
we hadn't had these big raises we'd be
selling some stuff oh yeah and they're
still gonna have to hustle yeah we're
gonna have to get after this you know i
i like classic cars in this situation i
i was very i was i was surprised a
little bit not at your philosophy but
i'd move one of those cars if the
classic car means a lot to the guy i
would downgrade in my everyday driver to
be able to pay off the classic car
that's me that i would want to fast but
i want to fast forward everything yeah i
don't want to struggle when i can make
one train got 80 000 bucks and you got
you know you got 24 months yeah so
you're gonna do beans and rice in order
to keep these cars is it really worth it
to me it's not what happens a lot of
times is when people get into that they
get about they get about six months into
it and they go screw it sell the car
that's right you're right they end up at
that conclusion and but you know because
right now in this conversation we love
these cars oh yeah but once you start
figuring out this is killing me all
right i'm having to live on nothing i
make 200 a year i'm living on nothing
these cars own me yeah and you'll dump
one of them then yeah i agree that's
what will happen but uh doesn't always
happen but it can't it can it can